[Music]
[Applause]
get ready Lion King lovers fans are sure
to feel the love after they see this
sneak peek of the 2019 remake one is
because I am a big fan of blanking too
because it's like the most expensive
movie I'll ever have anything to do with
probably so that's throwing Seth Rogen
shared a behind-the-scenes Pig in the
recording studio with his co-stars
Donald Glover and Billy Eichner
alongside director Jon Favreau it's
clear the cast is hard at work and we
have no worries they will nail the Belov
animated film Seth and Billy are set to
voice Pumbaa and Timon a natural fit for
the longtime friends is exciting when
you get to work with people that you
know well and yeah we're good friends
and so yeah I mean overall it's it's
surreal
[Music]
we recorded a bunch of the songs and
it's been me and Seth Rogen Donald
Glover
singing Hakuna Matata life is very
surreal fun almost all of my stuff that
I've recorded has been with Seth we're
playing off each other a lot of improv a
lot of some old stuff that people love
from the first movie new stuff I mean
you know we're making Timon and Pumbaa
our own which I know the world has been
dying for but we're having a blast and
there's a lot of pressure and they want
to get it right is it really you
who are you it's me Simba as for our
favorite Lion lovers the pressure is on
for Donald Glover to bring his unique
spin to King Simba
opposite Beyonce as the voice of Nala
from my my point of view but like
everybody was involved like no suit
really well like they're like so hear
the lyrics I'm like the lyrics don't
worry
like I was in fourth grade when this
came out like I so it's it's actually
been really great and just hearing her
do it it's been like man this is it's
really this is a really special thing
[Music]
[Applause]